foreign
MPS in a meeting with Tori back benches
known as the 1922 committee she's told
them to give her government more credit
after committing once more not to cut
public spending as trust is facing
growing pressure for another policy
reversal and was accused of trashing the
last 10 years of the tourist record at a
bruising meeting of the 22 committee and
in Washington her Chancellor quasi
quateng will today try to reassure the
IMF that everyone and everything is
under control after the institute's
chief Economist said tax cuts threatened
to cause problems for the UK economy
joining us now is the foreign secretary
James Cleveland hello team Mr cleverley
see you this morning thanks for joining
us
um she had another bruising day
yesterday actually going to turn this
around well look the Prime Minister when
she was running for the leadership of
the party made it clear that she felt
that we needed to bring taxation levels
down from the 70-year high the we are
currently looking at not put taxes up
further than they already are to make
sure we have growth in the economy and
to ensure that Ukraine is successful in
defending itself against Russia She is
delivering on all those feet on all
those three things
um and what she was saying to the 22 I
wasn't actually in the meeting but what
I know she said to the 1922 is that you
know we've got to make sure that we help
people keep more of the earnings in
their own Pockets that we've got to be
good custodians of the public purse but
we've got to grow the economy that's
what she's pushing for I think those are
our solid traditional conservative
governmental principles and I think we
should stick with it so you're going to
stick with a mini budget well the uh the
the
last time we spoke we talked about the
changes that the uh the chancellor has
had made to one of the elements of it
but ultimately what that mini budget was
about we should remind ourselves it was
about protecting tens of millions of
people from unaffordable Energy prices
so that was the bulk of that proposal it
was about making sure that taxes for 30
million working people were reduced a
little bit uh and those are really
strong principles and I absolutely think
we should stick with those okay so
there'll be no other changes there'd be
no more reversals on what happened well
the uh the chance
so the chancellor is going to be making
a statement on the 31st of October which
gives a more holistic uh assessment of
the public finances and our response to
the the global headwinds that every uh
democracy well every democracy every
economy in the world is facing but as I
say the the the the the foundations that
mini budget protecting people from
Energy bill prices letting them keep
more of their earnings protecting
businesses from those Energy prices
making sure that we're internationally
competitive all those things are really
key for the growth agenda that the prime
minister's put forward sticking with
corporation tax or not well I I mean the
chancellor the chancellor will come to
the uh to the dispatch box I think it's
absolutely right that we've made it
clear that we want to invest in
businesses and and when people talk
about you know taxing businesses I think
sometimes there's this idea that there
some faceless entities these are people
these are employees these are these are
the organizations that help people pay
their bills and actually they have been
under huge amount of pressure I talked
to businesses in my constituency they
have really felt the pressure and it's
absolutely right that we help them stay
competitive we help them stay afloat
that we help them uh uh compete
internationally employ people and pay
better wages and that's the kind of
thing that we should be doing and that's
why uh as I say the the package the
chancellor put forward is pro-growth and
is the right answer so you're sticking
with that then the chairman of the
education committee uh Robert Halford
um has been speaking in the 1922
committee as you know apparently he says
that Liz truss is trashing working-class
conservatism she's losing the back
benches unless she changes some of the
policies that she put forward as part of
the mini budget well look let's let's
remind ourselves what the proposition uh
put forward by the prime minister is she
says that first and foremost many of
these issues are Amplified by Putin's
brutal invasion of Ukraine and we need
to help the ukrainians defend their
defend their country we saw in the vote
in the United Nations last night we've
got an International Coalition of
condemnation against Russia in support
of Ukraine so support Ukraine 0.1 bring
taxes down a bit from their 70-year tax
burden high and grow the economy so that
we can pay for the public service if
people are saying one of those three
things are wrong I'll be very keen to
find out which of the those three things
people saying Adventures you have to
convince well again but let me look at
this quote look at this tweet it says um
Tori MP it was from one of my colleagues
at the Daily Mail Tori mp on let's try
this appearance at the 1922 committee it
was like someone trying to light a fire
using a magnifying glass using damp wood
in the dark these are the people that
she needs on side to get her policies
through yeah well look I mean some
people uh some people like having
quotable tweets and some people like
delivering good government I'm in the
camp of the kind of people that like
delivering good government I know that
the chancellor the Prime Minister and my
ministerial colleagues our focus on
delivering for the British people okay
if you don't want the tweets let's go
with Paul Johnson the ifs director try
as hard as we can given plausible
forecasts we can't see how to get public
finances on a sustainable path without
big painful spending cuts or a reversal
of the 43 billion pound tax cuts just
announced
well we have got to grow the economy
growing the economy is the way for well
the way we grow the economy is to make
sure we are internationally competitive
I'm the foreign secretary I travel
around the world and I can see other
countries you know tax and Regulatory
regimes and we have got to make sure we
compete internationally with the uh with
the other places that people and
businesses could choose to locate so
we've got to make sure that we are tax
competitive we've got to make sure we
are uh uh pro-growth that's why the
investment zones are so very very
important that's why making sure that we
don't have an unpredictable tax regime
which is why giving predictability for
people and businesses about tax is so
very very important because when you
grow the economy you can afford to fund
the Public Services on which we all rely
the Prime Minister has been clear that
we are going to fund Public Services
properly she's already made strong
announcements about the NHS about
increasing defense spending and other
areas but we have to be good cast
stadiums of the public person yes public
money is your monies your viewers money
it's not my money yeah to keep stepping
in to try to save our economy at the
moment Ian Duncan Smith is furious about
that for mature leader he's described
Andrew Bailey as stupid and the measures
that he has put forward as a mess do you
agree with him well look I I very much
value the independence of the bank of
England that means we've got to let them
do their job their job part of that part
of their job no of course he's not you
don't get to be you don't get to be
governor of the bank of England uh if
you're being stupid
um but the point is the the job of the
bank of England is to intervene it's
part of the strong institutions that
make the UK such an attractive offer
around the world he is doing his uh he's
doing his job it doesn't mean we always
agree with everything the bank of
England Governor says or does uh from a
personal point of view and Ian's totally
totally entitled to his view but he's
there for a reason the bank is there for
a reason they're doing the job job that
they do they're independent we've got to
let them get on with them but if you
want the Fig if you want to grow the
economy by two and a half percent which
is what you say has to happen in order
for these figures to work then how's
that going to happen given that the IMF
has said that the worst is yet to come
and for many people 2023 will feel like
a recession well we've seen the labor
party trying to uh you know trying to
create no trying to create this this
negative narrative no this is the idea
but but the point is if you actually
look at the figures you look at the
figures what you've seen is that
um earlier on in this year when we were
predicted to have negative growth we
actually had Positive Growth the
inflation figures that were predicted
we've come in lower those inflation
figures we've got lower inflation than
many of our competitors we have got
um uh interest rates which although
they're going up they're going up slower
than many of our International
competitors
every economy in the world is facing a
really really tough time I understand
yes 0.3 is the prediction for next year
but the point is that you can't look at
those you can't look at those growth
figures and say we want bigger growth
figures than that and then criticize
every measure that drives growth you
can't look at those and this is why we
talk about the anti-growth Coalition
because there are people that point to
that growth and so it's not high enough
and when the Prime Minister comes
forward and says well we should do this
this and this to boost growth they
oppose all those things as well
why are the markets so concerned about
what uh the budget said the mini budget
well we we've put in the media last time
no I didn't no I didn't no I absolutely
didn't God I absolutely didn't the point
that I put the the point that we have
been consistent about is we've got to
take the action that grows the economy
that means change change we completely
understand can sometimes be unsung when
you've had you know a decade-long uh way
of doing business way of doing
government on a prime minister comes
along and says I'm going to do things
differently of course that triggers a
reaction but as I say defending helping
the ukrainians defend themselves growing
the economy going for growth these
things are absolutely core to a
conservative guy but if the back benches
say she's wrong if the IMF says she's
wrong if the bank of England says she's
wrong if the market says she's wrong
surely
so I come back to the point I've made if
you at our core the core of what the
prime minister is saying is that we need
to be internationally competitive we
need to have growth in our economy and
we need to address some of the issues
that are driving uh these pressures the
war in Ukraine are over Reliance on uh
dictatorial regimes like Russia for
energy Supply in Europe these things we
need to address and it's all well and
goodness and again and we saw this the
other night with regards to votes and
the late party they're very very
critical but when we when when it comes
to putting forward an alternative no
alternative comes forward okay so going
for Budget will double down on what
we've already heard what we will come
what we will stay consistent with yeah
is the plan to grow the economy to
protect people from those Rising energy
bills to support the ukrainians
defending themselves against Russia to
address some of the international
drivers for the difficulties that we're
all facing we're at on you know we're
running out of Technology with a couple
of questions the India trade deal
they're not at all happy with what the
Home Secretary has said she said I do
have some reservations look at migration
in this country the largest group of
people who overstay are Indian migrants
as I said the Indians not at all happy
about that comment how will you fix that
next time you're there well we do have a
very strong relationship with uh India
the people and of course the Indian
government uh one of the I mean one of
the Hallmarks of a strong relationship
is you can have a very straight talking
conversation I met with the Indian
foreign minister my opposite number just
a few weeks ago we were able to talk
very very frankly and of course we do
want to have an even stronger and this
is strong already but an even stronger
trading relationship with India we want
to make sure
today well look the the point of view
you wouldn't have said it would you so
the points of being the foreign minister
is my job to to make sure the
relationship works on every level for
both countries that's exactly the
conversational that's exactly the
conversation I have when I when I when I
speak with the uh Representatives the
Indian government in the future do you
think that Queen Camilla should wear the
Karina or Diamond when she is crouched
well ultimately decisions like that are
for the palace what I have seen actually
um through the funeral arrangements for
late Majesty is the palace is really
very good at assessing the the public
and adibian's National mood ultimately
of course the decisions are for for the
the palace on issues like this
um but the Indians well look we we have
a fantastic relationship with uh with
with India and Indian people and as I
say you know it's a decision for the
palace
um and I have no doubt the coronation
will be an absolute celebration okay
final question before we let you go do
you support Harry Kane and the fa's
decision to wear a rainbow armband
um in Qatar for the World Cup well I
think that uh we stand by our values I
think the England football team stands
by the values of their home nation
they're a part of the UK we feel very
strongly about this I've had
conversations with the qataris about the
World Cup about our values well look
um oh again these are decisions for the
fa and individual uh footballers they
need to know that they've got their
foreign secretary behind them so the
point is I absolutely will support their
our national football team they're in an
international competition I want them to
win I've already said to the qataris I
very very much look forward to seeing
England uh in the final I can't remember
quite how these stages work out if it
can be England and Wales that'll be even
better still
um but uh would you wonder if it was
well I'm an English MP it's got to be
English there we go there we go you said
it it's good to see you always thank you
very much indeed thank you
let's have a look at what the uh papers
are saying this morning should we uh the
eye has the headline tour is in open
revolt against the Prime Minister as
back benches confront trust with anger
during yesterday's funeral funeral
1922 meeting in their words
a political turmoil is also covered by
the guardian the paper says trust faces
new Peril as Tories go on the attack
over the economy
rip up your tax plans top officials urge
trust deepening political divides also
shown by the Times newspaper
blue wall Falls that's on the front of
the Metro as the new poll predicts
dozens of conservatives could lose seats
at the next general election
the express tells of MPS attacking the
bank of England governor for stupid
comments
and the star tells of the cost of
loathing crisis details on couples who
have split up but can't afford to move
out because of the country's economic
woes
still to come on the program for you a
day after the PM's first pmq since the
mini budget will get reaction from
former advisors to both the main parties
talk to the General Secretary of the
communication Workers Union as more than
a hundred thousand postal workers walk
out this morning and pay
and in the next hour joined by the
shadow culture secretary that's Lucy
Powell
NATO defense ministers are meeting in
Brussels for the second day to discuss
how to best protect the Skies over
Ukraine in face of continuous Russian
bombardment but gears received a boost
overnight with Britain promising to send
anti-aircraft missiles for the first
time the defense secretary Ben Wallace
arrived at the summit a few minutes ago
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes was there and asked him why the
UK has committed to sending air defense
missiles and not the systems themselves
they'll join the American systems that
they're putting in they're the same type
of missiles so they'll complement that
and they'll just really really augment
the American sort of platforms and those
were the missiles they'll use and the
UK's gchq Chief this week warned that
Russia is running out of weapons given
the Allies hollowed out stockpiles is
there a risk that Western allies are
going to run out of weapons to support
Ukraine first no there isn't a risk
because unlike Russia who has already
isolated itself and we saw that
yesterday at the United Nations vote you
know they need a supply chain and large
parts of their supply chain were not in
Russia they came from all over the world
including in Europe and including indeed
in even in Ukraine some of their supply
chain was in Ukraine so we have the
ability to refurbish or indeed
manufacture a new supply chain which is
what we're doing right now and the UK
Danish joint-led international fund is
all about placing orders in a in
manufacturing space to make sure that we
can go on between 23 24 and keep going
on and next week NATO is going to be
holding its annual nuclear deterrent
exercises is that wise given current
tensions with Russia isn't there a risk
that that would just raise the chances
of a misunderstanding especially given
the language that Vladimir Putin is
using about his nuclear Arsenal well
Russia will also be conducting its
annual exercise I think the week after
or just after uh the annual
guys I think that's the key what we
don't want is to do things out of
routine this is a routine exercise and
it's all about readiness you know today
you know the NATO meeting is all about
making sure we are ready for anything I
mean that is the job of this Alliance is
to make sure that the 30 Partners
together are ready for what is thrown at
us and we have to continue work at that
and so exercising is part of that
Readiness including a nuclear attack by
Russia and Ukraine like how would the
NATO respond to that well I'm not going
to speculate I mean the fundamentals are
NATO is a an alliance of all types
conventional and nuclear powers and and
fundamentally we are here to make sure
our Readiness is for whatever is
Serenity is thank you very much
an American conspiracy theorist has been
ordered to pay nearly a billion dollars
in compensation to the victims of one of
the country's worst ever school
shootings Alex Jones had claimed that
the 2012 Sandy Hook shooting was a hoax
and that the families of the young
victims were actors are us correspondent
Martha Kellner reports
emotional stress damages past the future
58 million dollars bound together first
by the murder of their loved ones then
by the conspiracy theorist who
compounded their pain
the parents of five children and three
teachers slain at Sandy Hook Primary
School have been collectively awarded
almost a billion dollars
Alex Jones made their suffering his
multi-million dollar business
on his website Infowars he called the
Sandy Hook massacre a government
invention designed to remove people's
guns the parents he lied were crisis
actors who faked their children's deaths
or even invented children that never
existed
120 million
the biggest single award went to Robbie
Parker his six-year-old daughter Emily
was murdered at Sandy Hook Alex Jones
mocked him for years the harassment was
so bad Parker testified he had to move
thousands of miles from home for anybody
that still chooses to listen to that man
just ask yourself what has he ever given
you
and compare that to whatever it is that
he's taken from you
Jones was Shameless in the face of the
damages asking for donations to his
business they want to scare everybody
away from freedom and scare us away from
questioning eovaldi and what really
happened there or Parkland or any other
event and guess what we're not scared
and we're not going away and we're not
going to stop this will be framed by
Jones and his supporters as a
suppression of free speech but for the
families of the Sandy Hook victims it's
about putting an end to the lies and
defending the honor of their loved ones
Martha Kellner Sky News
and Alex Jones has said that he will
appeal that decision the head of qatar's
World Cup has said that gay fans will be
welcome at the tournament next month but
he also told English and Welsh
associations to focus on their teams
rather than demand compensation for
migrant workers he spoke with our
correspondent Rob Harris who joins us
now from DOA hi it's good to see you um
tell us more about what he said to you
yeah this was nasarakata responding for
the first time to that statement from
the Welsh and English fa's last month
about their calls for a worker
compensation fund to compensate those
who have suffered building all these
World Cup projects and infrastructure
around me here in Doha and his message
certainly is that they should be
sticking to focusing on their teams also
he's been asked to respond to the plan
to wear one love Rainbow armbands by
Harry Kane the England captain and
Gareth Bale The Well Skipper and
certainly he's left that decision to
FIFA well he believes they are political
statements perhaps that shouldn't be
taking place at this world cup he has
though been welcoming for gay fans who
have been concerned perhaps about coming
to this world cup
we've always said that everybody's
welcome here all we ask is for people to
be respectful of the culture what would
your message those fans be who are sort
of wary of maybe coming those lgbtq plus
fans everybody is welcome here and
everybody will feel safe when they come
to Qatar would that include say
everybody gay fans if they were holding
hands in public would that be okay yes
that's a message of reassurance to them
yes
so they could show some form of if I
held your hand Rob right now and I
walked outside the street for hours and
hours and hours nobody would say
anything to us
well nasarak Hatter did say that Qatar
cannot change its laws in terms of the
anti-lgbtq bus legislation says that the
world has to respect the fact that our
local cultures and traditions here in
Qatar they have changed laws to improve
worker conditions as they would see it
but rights groups say they haven't gone
far enough and there has been too much
suffering to build this country up to be
able to host the Middle East first World
Cup catalog has relaxed things like it's
alcohol policies so there will be drink
more widely available and NASA Arcata
the CEO of the World Cup reviewing there
will be drunk tanks to allow fans to
sober up in a country that isn't used to
such boisterous Behavior by fans or
indeed such an influx of supporters
we're just 38 days to go now until
thousands of fans are due to arrive and
kickoff comes 12 years after Qatar was
so controversially awarded This World
Cup okay for now thank you
and we hear them from the foreign
secretary about who he is supporting in
the world cup is it England or Wales you
can check that out on our Twitter feed
at K Burley now more than a hundred
thousand postal workers are walking out
this morning and what has been described
as the biggest ongoing dispute overpay
this year
let's find out more Ashton is standing
by for us on the picket line hi Ashley
what is it that they want
[Music]
because we're all male but also parcel
force is one of pay they are demanding a
pay rise but it's more in line with
inflation to reflect the rising cost of
living postal services will be disrupted
because of this action not only
affecting letters and Parcels that were
delivered yesterday or sent yesterday
but also today too this is action that
Royal males say is really brought on by
an issue of modernization more males say
that every single day since the pandemic
ended the business has lost one million
pounds per day they say they need to
move less towards letters and more
towards Parcels to allow them to compete
with other courier-based services which
operate for longer hours and seven days
a week this modernization they say if
the union the communication Workers
Union Gets behind it they will pay more
however the union stand by the fact they
say they feel as though this is an
assault on their jobs and they won't
back down they're already some 50 union
members behind me here they and to Stage
this action throughout the day there are
picket lines right across the country in
what is now the sixth day of action
there are 19 more days of strike Action
Now planned the latest of which will be
not only today but the 20th of October
and the 25th okay thank you
[Music]
also making news for you on the
breakfast show this morning police
looking for a missing teenager have
found human remains in a house less than
half a mile from where she was last seen
alive Leia Croucher was 19 when she
disappeared on the 15th of February 2019
in Milton Keynes sparking a massive
three and a half year search her
rucksack and other personal items were
also found at the home on loxborough
Drive in the firsten area after a
tip-off from a member of the public
a spending Watchdogs warned that
billions of pounds awarded as part of
covid-19 employment schemes were lost in
fraud and error the National Audit
office says the government should have
done more to prevent mistakes when
rolling out the follow scheme
a review into what happens to immigrants
detained in UK prisons has found that
they were disadvantaged compared to
those held in Immigration removal
centers the review found that many were
held in custody for a long period of
time with little or no progress in their
cases being made to the home office
a jet2 flight from Dalaman and turkey to
Manchester had to be escorted by RAF
Jets following a report of a Potential
Threat on board the plane was diverted
to London Stansted under the direction
of UK air traffic control the aircraft
landed safely and officers were able to
establish there was no threat on board
plans for Queen Camilla to be honored
with a crown containing the Kohinoor
Diamond at the coronation next year
could be dropped the controversial
Diamond was seized by the East India
Company in 1849 and presented to Queen
Victoria before featuring in the
coronation crown made for the queen
mother's coronation a spokesman for the
Indian prime minister's political party
has reportedly said that use of the
diamond could remind people of the
British Empire
we also asked the foreign secretary
about that again check out what he had
to say on our Twitter feed
um Liz truss actually met Kim Charles at
Buckingham Palace yesterday for the
second time uh here's what the king had
to say to the PM on her arrival see if
you can make out words
great pleasure
oh dear oh dear oh dear the king mutters
back again dear oh dear
um I don't know what's he referring to
well that remains a mystery of course
Liz trust was visiting the king not long
after a rather fiery round of pmqs where
she was forced to defend her mini budget
we've got to be good custodians of the
public purse but we've got to grow the
economy that's what she's pushing for I
think those are our solid traditional
conservative governmental principles and
I think we should stick with it so
you're going to stick with a mini budget
well the uh the the
last time we spoke we talked about the
changes that the uh the chancellor has
had made to one of the elements of it
but ultimately what that mini budget was
about we should remind ourselves it was
about protecting tens of millions of
people from unaffordable Energy prices
so that was the bulk of that proposal it
was about making sure that taxes for 30
million working people were reduced a
little bit and those are really strong
principles and I absolutely think we
should stick with those
tomorrow's here didn't say that they
were going to stick with the mini budget
I think you asked him three times K
whether he was going to stick with the
mini budget and the answer was not a
resounding yes we will stick with the
general principles he talked about the
energy price freeze which don't forget
was separate from the mini budget it was
done the week before freezing People's
Energy bills at a level above what they
paid last year but less than they would
have been and he talked about cutting
taxes for 31 million people that's
probably referring to the National
reversal of the National Insurance
increase which MPS voted through earlier
this week did he mention corporation tax
no did he mention that indeed no
commitment there did he mention the
stamp Duty measures no the expectation
among really quite large numbers of Tory
MPS
um from the conversations I was having
yesterday including ministers is that a
U-turn is in the offing on some of these
budget measures with all the
implications that holds for Liz trusses
credibility why because the chancellor
has to announce how he will balance the
books and he said he will do so on the
31st of October if there is Market
turmoil in relation to that statement
the general expectation is that Liz
truss's credibility will be further and
possibly fatally damaged so they need to
restore credibility and that means
coming up with some way of balancing the
books and if public spending cuts are
going to be politically difficult if not
impossible to get through Parliament
then that means you turning on some of
the signature measures that she
discussed throughout the leadership
campaign including keeping corporation
tax at a much lower level than had been
planned Tory MPS who met the Prime
Minister last night talked about the
mood being very Grim Robert Halford a
back bencher who was seen as a champion
of blue collar conservatism told her she
had trashed the last 10 years of what
we've been trying to do other MPS who
are not usually out there complaining
about their leader said that she had
sacrificed their reputation for economic
credibility it was a bruising session
and it's becoming increasingly difficult
to see how this trust turns this around
okay for now tomorrow thanks so much
indeed
well yesterday at pmqs list trust pledge
she wouldn't cut public spending saying
government debts will be paid for by
spending public money more wisely
meanwhile Zakir starmer called on her to
reverse what he called the Kamikaze
budget we'll be talking about that with
Claire Purcell former conservative
advisor and John mcternan a former
political advisor to the labor party
good to see you both thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
clear to you first of all your thoughts
on what we heard
well I think the moves in Parliament
yesterday was uh certainly one of uh
bleakness there are a number of MPS
wandering around just wondering how the
prime minister is going to come back
from this it was a very tricky prime
minister's questions no real questions
have been answered as to how we're going
to pay down the debt which is what the
markets want the country needs to
understand where it is if it's going to
be able to afford things like mortgages
rents electricity bills that kind of
thing and those are the answers that we
don't have and I understand the Prime
Minister doesn't want to you turn so
quickly but I think that in all fairness
that's all she can do at the moment to
save all of the crises that are going on
um and your thoughts on that John
uh I agree
um I think the mood of Tory MPS after
pmqs and later on after 1922 committee
uh was absolutely dire
um and some are definitely thinking how
can we put ourselves and our party out
of this misery uh pmqs was almost
surreal with the Prime Minister
um accusing labor and asking labor law
discretion accusing Kirsten review
turning when he devoted to Everett the
the National Insurance Levy he'd
actually he'd actually opposed and there
seemed to be at times so little
connection between the answers the Prime
Minister had the questions that Kier had
asked uh that there was two separate
conversations going on but a major
concession when she said that um there
wouldn't be spending cuts which really
undermines the whole preparation for the
medium-term financial strategy because
um it's not possible to square the
circle now which I think is why Tory MPS
are wondering how can they possibly get
themselves out of this buying and we are
37 days only into the trust Premiership
and this is still technically the
honeymoon period
um
I'm sure that um Claire that you saw
Penny morden's um
uh face
um a couple of times when we were
hearing the Prime Minister speaking at
the dispatch box uh what did you make of
that
I think it's kind of spoke for a lot of
us who are sitting and watching but I
thought it was quite interesting uh
Petty Morton was a candidate and would
have done very very well and it's almost
as if she's sitting there saying this
should have been my job but if you look
around the chamber at the time the faces
of many many Tory MPS were exactly the
same no one has an understanding of how
this is going to get better and I don't
think I've seen the mood this Bleak for
for such a long time even in the last
days of Boris Johnson there was a
certain kind of positivity among members
and that seems to have gone they don't
feel that they're being listened to so I
think that her face probably spoke for
the majority of the party and the
country
um it does look uh John as though um
later on in the 1922 committee that was
a challenge for the prime minister with
some very unkind comments finding them
their way onto Twitter
um later on
how important is it for the benefit of
my viewers this morning that she has the
1922 committee behind her
well in the end the only way a prime
minister governs in the UK Constitution
is by commanding a majority in that
Commons and if you don't have the the
support of your back benches because the
1922 is uh the shop stewards with the
Tory back benches if you don't have the
support of the back benches then who
does
keep you in office who is it is going to
vote for your measures you know the
government not only has to put forward a
medium-term financial strategy it's
actually going to have to put forth some
votes you know some issues to be worked
on if you can't you know you can't run
away forever you've got to put things up
will they will they pass or will they
fall
um and at the moment I mean I thought
the most telling uh comment that came
out from the the meeting last night was
somebody saying it was just a sad
meeting it was just a feeling of deep
sorrow and and that feels like the end
of a prime ministership not the
beginning
um and and you know we are just you know
we're less than a uh less than 40 days
into this so it it must feel terrible in
number 10 to be honest to not be able to
put things to a vote and believe that
you've got the back benches behind you
Claire if you were still offering
guidance and advice how would you sort
this
well I think I would probably say that
the Prime Minister should listen to the
room of the 1922 back bench MPS because
that is going to give you a flavor of
the mood of the party and what their
constituents are also telling them
because let's not forget that's the most
important thing MPS represent people
around the country and they want answers
so I think that she needs to take heed
of what was said to her by some really
senior backbenchers who are not the
rebellious types normally if they are
giving you that message you need to sit
and rethink you need to lay out your
plan very very clearly and get that
across to members as soon as you can
because I think that is the only way you
can reassure them that you're paying
attention you're listening and you're
willing to change
um and John what does Kia stama do does
he just sit back and um let them uh
infight or does he stick in the knife
he is talking about
couldn't get through to stick a knife in
the Prime Minister there's too many
conservative MPS surrounding her doing
that at the moment
um Kia has to look like an alternative
prime minister his front bench have to
look like an alternative government they
have to be very careful not to say
anything that Spooks the market a
discipline the self-discipline which
unfortunately senior Tory MPS like Jacob
Reese Mark don't appear to have in
attacking the obr yesterday
um there's a very strange disconnect
with the government refusing to take
responsibility and I think kyostarma has
to say labor look sound and will be
responsible as soon as this government
decide to put themselves and the country
out the misery have an election uh then
Kirsten is ready his team are ready and
that's why this week he put his put the
party on a warfating uh he moved his
organization into campaign mode and I
think you you prepare in the country but
in the Commons you have to look uh
server not exploiting the pain of the
government
um you really have to not take any Glee
in this this is terrible for the the
Tory party it's worse for the country uh
and it's so bad for so many people you
know 3 000 people a day coming off fixed
rate mortgages facing uh doubling
tripling of their of their mortgage
payments as we head into what was always
going to be a difficult winter
I was good to talk to both of you thank
you
let's trust this new government has
faced a backlash after lifting England's
fracking ban which was put in place in
2019 following a series of Earth Tremors
Greenpeace activists interrupted the
prime minister's speech at the
Conservative Party Conference accusing
her of shredding her party's Manifesto
promises on climate change uh as well
let's talk about it in more detail
should we move I'm going to chat to Our
Guest Harry Ramadan from dnv Energy
Systems hello it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning
um what are you making what we're
hearing from those trust no policies on
as far as the green environment is
concerned
I think it's really important that with
so much focus on high prices it's
natural there should be a focus on
energy security and different countries
around the world are responding
differently you've seen a response from
Europe to double down on Renewables
what's important is that some countries
where cost is the main driver will also
focus on coal
DMV's energy transition Outlook report
which was published this morning really
highlights that the short-term
turbulence in the energy markets will
not
set off course the energy transition and
Today's Energy System well today's
Energy System is 80 based on fossil
fuels our report which looks at the
whole of the World shows up by 2050 51
of the energy system will be based on
non-fossil fuels most of that powered by
Renewables wind and solar but that's the
good news the bad news in our report is
that we missed the Net Zero Target which
I know your organization studies very
closely every evening we miss that Net
Zero Target by Miles and we have to
double down our actions and our
investments every year for the next 30
years if we're to hit Net Zero so how
much do we miss it by
um essentially the 1.5 degree carbon
budget that the Paris agreement is based
on will be gone by the end of the decade
and we'll be heading towards two degrees
by 2050. and what does that mean for the
planet
um that's really bad news I mean just
recently in the last few weeks we've
seen the floods in Pakistan in Florida
tens of millions of people affected in
Europe how can we forget the last summer
40 degrees in the UK 50 degrees in
Europe the impact of climate change in
DMV's analysis is something like 17 to
18 of the world's GDP the cost to do the
energy transition is more like one to
two percent so we really can't afford
inaction at all but you have also
highlighted an increase in Coal over the
next year or two is that something to be
concerned about adding to that concern I
think that's the response when energy
security dominates you've got high
prices and not everyone can afford the
gas prices are incredibly high and
therefore some countries will switch
towards coal there's also an aspect of
energy resilience and when the markets
are tight for gas and electricity uh
coming from either Renewables or gas
it's inevitable that in the short term
coal will have to be burned and because
it's important the lights don't go out
so you support uh refiring or firing up
up the coal-fired power stations in the
UK well I think the UK has to there's
you know you can't afford for the lights
to go out so yes the UK has done a great
job and they're all done in time for
this winter though will it no I mean the
commitments to increase offshore wind
from 10 gigawatts to 40 gigawatts it's
fantastic and the UK has come a long way
in its use of Renewable Power but this
winter
um and All the Troubles we have from
Ukraine and Russia and the impact on gas
means that gas supplies and electricity
generation is tight and in that scenario
I think it's important to look after
business and society and therefore if we
have to burn coal in the short term it's
an inevitability for energy security
reasons
where'd you stand on fracking
I think in overall terms DMV always
talks about an energy system and you
need to balance that energy system and
we need our own domestic
um energy and that can come from
Renewables it can come from onshore wind
it can come from solar what's important
is the government outlines a plan in
which decreasing oil and gas and
increasing Renewables is part of it but
you can't just switch off the oil and
gas we need it to meet our energy
demands today
um governments saying that fracking and
for the North Sea oil extraction is
green and good for the environment
yeah I'm not so sure I'd go that far I
mean the oil and gas industry itself has
to lower its carbon footprint and at
some point we have to decarbonize the
gas itself and there we have carbon
capture and storage and we can also
produce hydrogen and that's part of the
energy transition that has to happen but
the most important thing is that every
country including the UK has a range of
activities because no one energy source
will solve the energy transition it's
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed where do we find more about your
report is it online yes it is at dmv.com
energy transition Outlook fantastic
thank you thank you so much
back to the Royal Mail strike where more
than a hundred thousand postal workers
are walking out this morning in what has
been described as the biggest ongoing
disputes overpay this year joining us
now is Dave Ward he's the General
Secretary of the communication Workers
Union hello chief thank you for joining
us on the program again Dave always good
to see you
um it's not long since we were having
this same conversation how much further
have you got
sorry Kaya I'm struggling to hear that
okay I know there's a lot of music going
on behind you this morning I was saying
it's not long since we had this
conversation have you got any further
since we last spoke
it's uh it's not coming through sorry
hang on a sec okay we'll try and sort
that out for you and we'll come back to
you in just a second I know Ashton has
done there as well so we'll do what we
can mean time to Somalia where the
United Nations is warning that Somalia
is facing catastrophic hunger after
years of drought and sporadic rains have
destroyed food security let's get more
now from yusra
the sky's promise rain but even when
they come it won't be enough
this is the worst drought the region has
seen in 40 years
and the threat of terror group al-shabab
continues they're Fighters stalking the
edges of these camps nearly a million
people in Somalia have been displaced by
extreme hunger and more than half of
them are here baido is a town that has
many displacement camps and they're well
established but every day they keep
growing as more people arrive
close to half of somali's population is
now in need of food assistance
why did you come to this camp
foreign
has become the epicenter of a looming
famine the human cost of climate change
and its young children who are suffering
the most what's wrong with her yeah
this won't be the first time Somalia
faces famine in 2011 more than 200 000
people lost their lives nearly half of
them were children
is a year old I can't even stand upright
because his legs are too weak to carry
him
he's just been discharged from this
Center an emergency care facility
helping stabilize malnourished children
inside the ward it's a chorus of Christ
how is this situation different to when
famine was declared in 2011. people are
going to be done because of the belong
so there is a insecurity and a long drug
so you think it's going to be worse yes
if it is going like this it will be more
than more than one yeah it was here as
one will be
it will be the serious one
if the rains come do you think it will
get better
no because of the raining
it takes time I'm so sorry
[Music]
for some hair help has come too late
just like the rains
they're from at shabab control territory
under a reign of terror the chances of
survival are Slim
[Music]
drought hunger conflict
a battle on all fronts
Sky News Somalia
we're talking about that in more detail
with the World Health Organization later
on in the program meantime let's see if
we've got Dave Ward back the General
Secretary of the communication Workers
Union on strike today his members hi
Dave can you hear me now
fantastic that's great fantastic I was
saying making the point that it's not
that long ago since we were speaking
um in a very similar situation how much
further have you managed to get since
then
well it's very difficult to negotiate
any settlement to this dispute because
postal workers are facing the biggest
assault on their pay jobs terms and
conditions in the history of Royal Mail
and what the company did as you you know
they imposed a two percent pay increase
when they made record profits of 758
million they now want to manage out
existing employees in the business
through unagreed performance standards
and they want to bring in new workers on
20 less pay and increase their working
week by three hours at the same time for
businesses and for the public what they
want to do is end basically daily
deliveries start three hours later so
deliveries wouldn't be going out to 12
o'clock and in relation to Parcels which
we want to deliver and capture parcel
growth they want to hide that off into a
separate business with self-employed
owner drivers and I I have to be honest
K there is no Prospect of us agreeing
that type of asset strip in business
plan and a leveling down agenda we're up
for modernization but I would stress to
your viewers and you can come and
scrutinize these proposals this is not
modernization this is asset strip in
leveling down of the worst salt
the Royal Mail was saying response
they're losing a million pounds a day
since covid and they need to try to find
savings somewhere
well look let's scrutinize that as well
let's have a government inquiry into
what they're saying because what we know
is a fact is that they made 758 million
pounds last year when we had an
agreement on change and that agreement
was instrumental in bringing the company
through the pandemic postal work has
done a fantastic job and we changed at
the same time and they made money in a
matter of three or four months they're
now saying that they're losing a million
pound a day well if that's true the
people are running this business should
be sacked for gross mismanagement
because what they've actually done is
abandoned the process of change in favor
of this asset stripping business plan
and we are absolutely certain it is
linked to
the company that's trying to buy Royal
Mail which is a private Equity
Investment Group based in Luxembourg
this is an absolute disgrace and you
know we welcome any scrutiny on this and
I would urge you to scrutinize Royal
mails actual proposals rather than what
they're saying about modernization
there's no same worker in the UK that
would accept what the company are
putting forward and you know we are
determined our members are absolutely
determined to make sure that we succeed
with Royal Mail we've got ideas we've
got plans for change we want change we
want modernization but not on the terms
of something that is going to destroy
this business and the jobs of our
members
uh just a quick thought on Christmas
um impact on customers for Christmas
well you know the company about the NC
um when they said to us the other week
about going to acas at the same time
they handed us a letter uh that where
they ripped up all of the agreements
that the union has and that protect our
members jobs and then they said let's go
to acres I mean they've opened up the
chasm so our response to that was to
signal that we are up for this for the
Long Haul we're not walking away from
this dispute but let me be absolutely
clear we want an agreement we don't want
to be on strike postal workers don't
want to be on strike and I'd like to
think that even the government would do
some sort of inquiry into what's going
on there this is one of the greatest
companies in the UK and it is being
ripped apart not by workers not wanting
modernization by the type of program
that you see all too often across the UK
which is destroying the UK economy and
the idea that we're going to have a high
wage and growth in the economy when
companies are getting away with this
sort of attack on workers it's just
ludicrous so you know we hope it doesn't
come to Christmas we hope we can get
them into a position where they abandon
that program and get back to the
agreement that we actually had which by
the way Kate the CEO and the chair of
the company actually signed up to that
agreement only 18 months ago and the
same two people are destroying this
business now it's not on
uh thanks for joining us on the program
um keep in touch thank you
thank you
thank you
astronomers have captured an image
resembling a cosmic fingerprint
thousands of light years away here we go
if you look closely you can see 17
dustering somebody's counted them by the
James Webb Space Telescope each ring was
created when two stars came close
together and streams of gas collided the
orbit of the Stars only brings them
together about once every eight years is
what I'm being told they're going it's
like it's quite cool actually isn't it
really cool let's have some more cool
pictures for you uh here we go these are
some of the ones that have occurred RI
this morning a large Mosaic that dates
back to the Roman era has been
discovered in the town of rastan in
Syria Syrian officials said it is the
most important archaeological find since
the conflict began 11 years ago and this
may look like a piece of junk but it
went under the hammer at Sotheby's for a
whopping
14.4 million pounds I don't think it
looks like junk I think it's very
elegant actually however the buyer has
been prohibited from sitting on it the
Cherry is only one of six surviving
folding antique chairs from the 17th
century China Ming Dynasty and was used
by a traveling dignitary that's pretty
cool and uh curator Emma Bowen polishes
the silver guilt Doncaster girl cup that
forms part of a dazzling array of
stunning silver centerpieces that have
been restored and prepared ahead of
going on show in a newly revamped
display at Temple Newsome house in Leeds
that's a great picture as well isn't it
fantastic need a bit more elbow grease
than that I think though uh still to
come on the program before you're going
to be talking in more detail about the
um woes for our prime minister as her
um chancellor has gone to Washington to
speak to the IMF they've not been very
complimentary about his mini budget we
were putting to James cleverley the
foreign secretary about some of the
challenges that this trust has been
facing seems to be losing the support of
her back benches what next we'll have
more on that coming up in a moment
[Music]